uh
and and we're live
okay welcome to the weekly poll guys I'm
Benny the comic story and joined by the
entire Justice League okay so what we
have today let's see if I can do this
that is s he's okay I'm just gonna go
s's Batman uh he's over at TV little
house he's Batman we got fy's Aquaman
yeah you got to give him Aquaman's so
he's he's over from it's super effective
we've got armeni he's Wonder woman and
he's from uh I have an actual woman and
he's Wonder Woman no I'll gladly take
it I only have so many Justice League
members to go through I'm already
running out of the important ones
Firestorm rooster gold Blue Beetle blood
wind fine fine you get to be Blue Beetle
you can no one wants to be blood
win not even blood win wants to be that
that
is that is Rob from Marvel explained AKA
Comics explained also known as John
Stewart The Green Lantern
I'm actually actually that was totally
unplanned and I had no idea that I was
considered John Stewart from Green
Lantern but I will happily take that
mantle on and and the last guy on the
list is Joel he gets to be
Alfred God damn it master Bruce I'm
gonna throw this hot tea in your
face I
drew this this is Superman actually
after a couple of years he's been eating
a lot of Cheetos and just playing
internet games you know he's got a a
little extra beer going here he's just
kind of giving up you know y yeah um I'd
also like to take this time to tell
everybody in the chat to take this
moment to just let Benny know how
fantastic his hair looks because he's
been working on it the entire
pre-show the whole show he's been like
guys
please so my hair D my hair thing
because I got commented this my Q&A this
morning think what is wrong with your
hair so I don't normally make
appearances early in the week like on
these things so when I get my haircut I
get the side shaved so it grows into the
fade that I'm looking for to go with
everything but if but the first couple
of days is like just like a nuclear
explosion happened on my head I don't
really know what happened
there see people are saying that like
Benny's competing with f for like the
best hairstyle which I think need it's
so hard his hair is amazing we need we
need to have that we need to have like
the top three hairstyles of like the
YouTube comic book
YouTubers like that F number one too F
get number one only show his oldest of
video
oh my
God watch Mojo what were you guys
thinking going on my hair and my goal is
to eventually compete with FS for the
hairo I'm working on it you know every
time that I'm like oh it might look okay
F shows up with a better hairo
so the best part is I'm going back I'm
going back to my blue and red hair
because people preer that oh I mean I'm
a Kentucky like I'm from Kentucky and we
have the Kentucky wild cat so blue and
blue and white hair needs to come back
all right so guys um first thing I want
to say is we've decided to go more on
format more keep it on topic we we have
agreed to give you guys that weird
episode once a month where we do just go
off the cuff but it will be put with a
disclaimer and it will be the weird poll
where basically we don't know where this
this discussion is gonna go yeah so the
other three days three week days out of
the the month we will be giving you a
proper podcast So today we're going to
be talking about uh the badir
controversy which is why Tiffany from TV
Little House Fame is joining us thank
you for being here today Tiffany of
course um and we are also going to be
discussing the new releases for
convergence and Marvel Secret Wars we're
going to get as far as we can within our
lot of time salot but that is like 90
something books it's nuts man it's
absolutely skip a couple of these I
think that's why we have so many people
on the podcast today because we're going
to get everyone's varying opinions and
everyone will just take a book and talk
about it off this list so might as well
man I mean it' be the easiest for like
everybody take two
books just split it all up yep so and
haggus explained we'll be on the next
weird poll we'll have that don't worry
yeah well we we'll have F and he will
give us the intricate nature of how it
is that haggus is made and why it even
exists in the first place so he's
goingon to be so pissed it's from the
haggus dragon uh the hagus
dragon wow I want to see where that one
goes all right so let's let's go ahead
and start our topic today our first
topic the Batgirl situation um as
because I did the joke opening just so
you guys know uh today we have comic
story and we have Comics explain we have
TV little house we have it's super
effective and we have two guys REM comic
bookcast everyone can be found by what I
just said and all their links will be in
the description down below when Rob
fixes it because I know he didn't do it
at launch
oh way to call the man out actually he's
100%
right I will have you know that is true
I will have you know that he is not
wrong I assemble those remarks so our
first topic of the day came out earlier
today we were we were just going to talk
about convergence secret war and their
issues but because this happened today
we figured it' be a great topic to talk
about they released a cover for Batgirl
what a preview of the cover that was
coming up it was a reference to The
Killing Joke in which the Joker shot her
in the stomach paralyzed her and uh
various other things I mean you can you
can I think I think all of us have
covered it at this point so you can go
see what's happening with the Killing
Joke nasty bad things that yes but the
problem but I'm sorry I have to stop you
right there Benny the Joker's Hawaiian
shirt was fantastic it really was it was
pretty amazing oh he does well it's
because you know he's wearing a tropical
shirt but he's so white so like he
really needs the sun you know it looks
like he's on vacation and he can really
the tan didn't work out no by the way
can we also alternatively call this
episode how I got blocked by Cameron
Stewart on Twitter oh really we're gonna
get to that in a minute we're not there
yet we're not there yet okay all right
so anyway so what end up happening is
the cover came out um there was a series
of backlash for a number of reasons uh
people not liking it being refer
refenced people deciding that the new
Batgirl's direction is a little more
kid-friendly and how can you have
kid-friendly and then reference these
awful incidents that happened to her a
whole number of things and the artist
requested the cover get pulled and it
has now been pulled down so now now that
the cover has been pulled not only do
you have the original people who were
fighting against the cover but now you
have an entire core of people who are
fighting to keep the cover a bunch of
people yelling censorship who I don't
think quite understand the definition of
censorship
exactly so that is what the situation is
now um we brought Tiffany here and S you
know best what's going on with the with
the camera situation so why don't you
guys take point for the discussion at
this point okay uh well as we know
Cameron Stewart's the right on bgirl
Eisner award-winning author and he uh
he's one of the most vocal or at least
the most like obvious
uh uh pick your words carefully yes he's
not a fan let's put it that way and I
don't like I don't know necessarily I
can't say whether he asked to have it
pulled but he certainly has said
publicly that the cover the variant
cover that we're talking about by the a
variant
cover was never uh was was never run by
him or the artist on Batgirl uh and so
he never got to approve it which like I
don't think that's ever a thing uh first
of all so you know sorry for that uh and
second that it completely violates the
tone that they're going for with that
girl it changed the entire Spirit of the
book and so like he was happy to see it
go um and then jump on Twitter and he
was kind of like explaining and then
reinforcing his point and anyone who
jumped on Twitter and either I F you
know what's funny the the what I noticed
was actually one of our one of our
viewers reached out to me on Twitter and
he was like got blocked by Cameron
Stewart uh I said something and he told
showed me the Tweet incredibly tame
something like you know I don't even
understand what's go like I don't
understand the controversy
blocked and this comes on the heels of
Stuart getting into a big old Twitter
war with Eric lson just reason why
tian's here yeah of the back which which
that's a whole another kettle of fish I
don't want to get into the girl in
general like no and well it's been a lot
you know what I there's an old Hollywood
saying there's no such thing as bad
publicity and but the only the only
thing that is bad is that like you're
pulling this this cover that will be in
the news because of this [__] for
lack of a better term yeah uh and so you
know now you're not you're losing sales
and especially trumped up uh
overinflated sales because it's a
variant cover so it's going to be it
would have been you know that much more
expensive um you it's it's it's a weird
thing uh and it's funny because I
remember a week ago seeing the outcry
and showing you and going is this
offensive and then you were like not
really and I'm like fair enough and then
today it explodes I'm like oh it was
like a time bomb non-comic readers in my
Twitter feed were going off about it I'm
like were you guys even reading the book
no yeah okay just checking yeah I mean
overall how do you guys feel about the
cover you've all seen it right well I
mean I didn't understand like I didn't
realize at the time that they were going
for a lighter tone on back R because I
really haven't gotten to the new 52 back
R yet like she I will say this I I don't
know who's been reading backgirl if I'm
the only one I don't know have you been
read okay so yeah they are they are
completely changing the tone it's
actually a fun debate that Sal and I
keep having as to how old is she
supposed to be now because I've been in
on that too I've been in on that too
because I while I do enjoy the book I
mean when you poke at it you're like
isn't she like 32 a little too old to be
dressing like
that by the way not to say like she
shouldn't be dressing like that I'm just
saying like she's she's tweeting it up
and she's hanging with you know I'm like
you're 30 like m to the and what makes
it even funnier is like she's been
established as this very levelheaded
very together woman who's got a nice
career she dresses very conservatively
when she's not in costume and and then
they did a ple 180 on that they're like
oh now she's trendy now she's wearing
doct now yeah oh but guys there might be
a reason for that they're building up to
what the reason for that might being oh
no they they've already explained they
they already revealed that that should
have people more pissed off the thing
where they're like hey you know that
Gail Simona run You Loved Before and was
critically acclaimed and sold great that
was an evil computer in controller not
that actually happened I want to ask you
guys a question though regarding cuz I'm
a man who loves variant covers um
Guardians are 1 when that came out I
have every cover up on my wall I
absolutely love all of them now a lot of
those covers don't necessarily reflect
what's in the comic and I know like Star
Wars number one has Co has covers I'm
like well I don't want my daughter C
next it's like a little more you know
out there and I'm like J got Campell
cover yeah right so what is the
difference well that was my point that
that was my thing like it's one thing if
they said okay like this one issue is
going to be a total break away from her
storytelling so far which has been more
you know pre-teen friendly and just make
it like really sadistic it's not like
they're rewriting The Killing Joke she's
not going to get shot again right and so
like all it was the cover was just a
homage to one of the most pivotal
moments in Batman continuity you know
let alone like Batgirl continuity and so
I I think that it wasn't terrible I mean
I think it was kind of a cool thing I
think it was kind of a cool way to maybe
at the very least give a tip of the hat
to really old readers Who had who had
read The Killing Joke and who just you
know was like hey guys look like we
still haven't forgotten it was still a
great story here's just our
acknowledgement that yes it's still a
great story and then just leave it at
that I mean it well and they were
running they they were running like it's
Joker week so every book in DC has a
joker version of like has a joker themed
cover and if you're going to do a
Batgirl book and they're like oh Joker
is going to be in your Batgirl cover
what story are you gonna pay exactly oh
you're gonna do the killing joke because
what's their relationship that yeah um
now that's that that said I I've
actually been thinking about this a lot
and I had a lot of time to do it because
I was in the car all day and uh one of
the things that I one of the things I
was thinking about was uh somebody like
somebody on Twitter changed the eyes I
don't know if you guys saw that there
was like she's more def instead of more
of a victim yeah I she's much less uh
submissive and much more angry about
Joker brutalizing her yeah and they said
that changes everything number one does
it number two uh I should say like I was
re-examining the cover and does it
depict a woman being brutalized I say
yes uh well what they're saying is that
it references The Killing Joke and the
controversy that arrived Around The
Killing Joke in general because there
were two schools of thought on that
either they didn't like care for the
fact that it was like the girlfriend in
the refrigerator yes the old girlfriend
in the refrigerator they said it was
that syndrome and other people said no
it wasn't that at all right and the
people who aged with that now are going
to have an issue with it and then you
have a bunch of people who are just like
well no I just want to I want to yell
about this yes and you know to them they
see it and that's what they think of as
opposed to examining the cover itself
and examining the character who are
involved the fact is it's not the
Punisher who's doing this who is a
questionable hero to begin with it's a
villain it's a villain that we know is
batshit insane it's a villain who we
know is almost the essence of evil who's
doing this and no way are they saying
that this is a rational action and no
way are they saying that this is
something you should TR TR to do this is
a fact of this world unfortunately this
happens and sometimes we have to face
that we have to understand that this
type of thing happens in the world and
if you can't look at it on a on a comic
book cover then how can we even begin to
start accepting that it happens and
trying to fix it that is an amazing
point and let's also keep in mind too if
if what what DC was really looking to do
here was to take the idea of the killing
joke and say okay let's find a way to
victimize bad girl and put that on the
cover they could have taken the scene
where the Joker had shot her and then
took pictures of her and just like put
that on the cover it clearly not
designed to be that way that's another
thing that's blowing my mind because I'm
hearing new interpretations or new
interpretations of the killing joke that
I either chose not to interpret or just
never got yeah which is the time between
the photographs being taken and when B
girl was taken to the hospital and
apparently there's like implied rape in
that situation yeah I read about that
too that was also not something that I I
would never assumed the Joker like I I I
don't know about you guys and this is
this is talking from like 20 years of
reading comics and and just be and an
English teacher I never saw the joker as
a sexual being yeah I always saw him as
being very asexual myself like he he
just doesn't do that right and it's like
he might that's also why Brian azarel's
Joker really bothers me oh yeah because
he brings the sexuality into why like
who cares also like thanks for your fan
script for you know Batman 3 but uh the
um but the fact like also the Harley
quinnn thing like when she was first
created I'm like why do Joker a
girlfriend he hasn't have like he hasn't
need one of those but they really kind
of played that up in the show where he's
like she's interested in him and he's
like yeah that's that's exactly what I
was gonna say like I'm sorry go ahead oh
oh just just the fact that like would
the Joker use rape in his like as one of
his many acts of violence I know like I
I think I don't know I would never put
anything past the Joker but as far as
the killing jokes concern I don't think
that I I never interpreted it to be that
way no I interpreted like the the nude
pictures of her supposed to Rattle J
supposed to rattles it's it's it's her
and her most vulnerable state and it's
that connection of father and daughter
not like a lording over you know male
over female like thing that's happening
like that's just how I interpreted it of
course it is it is up to interpret is up
to interpretation so people are going to
see it either way but so is the cover
then and the fact is you have one group
saying like no it's this and that's and
then they they're completely unwilling
to accept anything else and now it's
been pulled and whether or not that's
right well yeah it's really up to
everyone's interpretation that's true DC
is gonna cover their ass like whether it
was the artist who asked to pull the
writer has to pull it no matter what
their business and they're going to pull
it because they're worried about that on
the other hand when that um ridiculous
cover for Spiderwoman came out they
didn't pull that no they put a logo over
it right what Happ by the way that's
where the logo goes so I don't really
like I would I would have to compare
like if they made the logo a little
bigger just and even like in that case
like not to dig up an old thing where
it's like the Spiderwoman cover it's
like you got an artist of erotica of
course he drew ex once you du you were
like okay well what what were you
expecting but but at no point that
anyone yelling about it mentioned that
it was representing brutalizing a woman
so therefore they're like well whatever
I don't care I don't care if it like
seual sexualized women or it might
demean them I don't care about that but
DC is worried about this overall image
like and when you come down to it their
business and that's what they're going
to worry about yeah well I I think the
problem is is The Killing Joke itself
because you said it best because Sal and
I were talking about this when I had to
write The Killing Joke storyline yeah
there that for what is literally just a
story about Joker trying to Rattle Jim
Gordon and trying to prove to Batman
that a one bad day can mess with a man
and then Jim Gordon proving that he's
better than that has turned into by
interpretation Batman killing the Joker
the you know Batman going insane with
the joker they're being supposed raped
they're being all these other things
which is why when I even did the story
for Killing Joke myself I was like we're
just going to touch on because because
we're already going to get controversy
we're just going to be like bad things
happen and just leave here's what
happens in the panels I'm looking at
right it's because of that that and the
fact that no one has actually read The
Killing Joke at this point like that
that's the biggest problem I think most
people know of The Killing Joke what's
the Killing Joke oh that's the Joker's
origin story and the one where he raped
back girl did you read it do you know
you know and then people just assume
that and they see that image and like oh
so we're just going to we're going to
bring up the one he raped battir for the
record this is where it kind of
irritates me with them censoring that
first off it's the variant so it's not
the main storyline so you're only going
to get that if you're looking for this
awesome piece of art secondly um The
Killing Joke storyline they want to
pretend like it didn't happen but the
problem is that is like you said Tiffany
what happened in this world it's a makeb
believe world that the comic do
reference quite a bit like when death of
the family happened and they were like
back girl do you want to sit this one
out she's like no I'll deal with this
you know things like that badir is built
on the back of the killing Joe recovered
from it not only that like they I was
going to say just sorry not to guys but
like they've done numerous books pre-
New 52 pre like new like logos where
Batgirl SL Oracle deals with the joker
oh yeah and like and she also has like a
like a photographic memory or something
like that so she'll like never forget
right and like but they've had her come
to terms with what happened and fight
the Joker or deal with him in some way
like we've seen that that that combat
and that like that that come back again
and again well not just that himself
even makes mention of it in this newest
run in an art gallery where there's a
bloody wheelchair himself is making
reference this in this supposed teen
friendly like teeny bopper like
bubblegum chewing Book Adventure yeah no
I can I can understand the artist's
problem with it like the writer he's
like well look we didn't approve this
we're trying to go away from the old
school be we want to make her more
teenage friendly and I really don't
appreciate the cover him taking a stance
where he's like I don't like it fine
yeah the internet going on insane upros
over that thing is a little much it is a
bit much it definitely is I mean look
the fact is like I understand like
people there are people out there who
will always look at the killing joke and
be like no this is just a woman being
used in order to like make a male
character stronger there's there's going
to be people out there and you're never
going to change their mind but even if
you look at it like that then you have
to look at what comes afterwards because
the fact is after Barbara Gordon is
crippled she's actually a way better
character she comes back she becomes
stronger yeah oracle's a way more devel
character but I mean as a as a human
being alone she is able to get over a
crippling injury literally and yeah
literally
and become B basically like Batman's
right-and man and not just help not only
Batman the DC Universe is right exactly
so I mean the fact is like if you're
going to examine her from that
perspective then you have to examine
what comes afterwards and otherwise you
can't talk of it and that's I'm going to
leave it well but that's that's the
problem you have is is people like in
this day and age people select the facts
they want and like like a really good
example is is like I was talking to
benan S about the killing joke and I was
like okay guys like The Killing Joke is
a story about the joke origin right and
Benny's like that's like one part of it
but like this great big picture is like
barara Gordon being shot and the
aftermath of you know what it means for
the Batman Community with her being shot
and so I was like okay and and that's
that to me that really kind of hits hits
the Hallmark there when you have a
person that doesn't really know exactly
what's going on with the killing joke
like the significance of the Killing
Joke until you sit down and read it and
that that was that was my stance up
until I read it like I knew what it was
I knew the significance of the killing
joke I just didn't know what all it
entailed and problem that you have I
think is is just like you know just like
Benny said and S and Tiffany said is
that you have people who say okay the
killing jok's a story about a woman
getting shot and then like she's
paralyzed and then something about the
Joker's Origins whatever but by God it's
a violent story and this should not be
tied into the current run of back R and
and they just have no real idea what's
going on and so you know I'm really
hoping that that at the very least even
if Minds can't be changed with regards
to their stance on what's going on and
and coming to the moment at the very
least like issues like this despite the
fact that sometimes they're blown out of
proportion will go towards the direction
of helping people understand one it's
just a comic book and two like what you
see on the cover of this comic book is a
very significant aspect in the history
of her character of her as a person of
what it is that she used to be what
happened to her and what she became
after that happened and so like to me
it's just kind of I don't know kind of a
clearing up of things I guess let me ask
you something guys real quick I know um
Jason Todd is no longer a 15-year-old
boy right what wait he may be with the
way he acts yeah tell sure writes them
that way what if they had done a variant
where Rood and the Outlaws or something
like that where Joker had cornered a
15-year-old boy dressed like Robin with
a crowbar what do you think the reaction
would have been and I bet it would have
been very little even though that shows
the that shows possible brutalization of
a child
essentially that's well that's and
that's the difference that you find like
that
that's that's what you find I think
people are more apt to jump into the
role of being a white knight when it
comes to the depiction of women in in
comics in an unfair way more so than a
guy instead of just what they really
should be doing is just looking at it as
a whole and the message that Comics as a
whole put out there like certainly there
are uh certain tropes and stereotypes
you're going to find no matter what and
over time those might be changing we'll
see but the fact is like if you're going
to talk about the brutalization of a
woman then you have to look at as a
child I mean the Joker beat to death a
15 old with a crowbar based on a hotline
yeah like if you're going to examine one
thing you got to examine it all you're
talking about that I like to ask you
guys something because um a lot of
people are going to be watching us that
are fans of CBC know I'm a giant Magneto
fan and that extent also Quicksilver
scarrett witch are two of my favorite
characters in comic history um and
imagine today as sensitive as the world
is and we see what the internet now
gives everybody a voice and we can pull
covers and all that right um if they
were to do the ultimates number eight
which the cover AB abolutely love cuz
it's detrimental to the story of where
the characters are where Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch are looking intimate right
and their brother sister yeah knew going
that direction if that was to release
today with the charact with a variant
cover of the people from the movie how
quick do you think that would be pulled
I don't think it would have got TW yeah
I mean I think it wouldn't go anywhere
I'm gonna be one of those guys that at
New York Comic-Con this year I'm gonna
have that drawn as a variant being like
look at me I'm you know I'm awesome AR
I'm controversial but I'm AR the
maker few months ago that everyone's
kind of gotten over well I don't know
how people would react because I mean
the fact is like if you know think about
like Japanese culture and like you know
anime and manga over there like that's a
big thing for them like oh brother
sister love stories yeah they're really
big into that and as manga comes anime
and manga you know has invaded like
America and American audiences like I'm
wondering if people would have that same
staunch reaction to it or would they be
like whatever I don't knows
exactly as long as you're pretty blonde
people it's fine hold on everyone hold
on F is trying to speak and when he
speaks he's going to blow up the entire
room he is like people people have been
saying like f needs to say
something CH saying he won't talk
because if he whispers he will derail
every
conversation my whole point of view on
this whole situation is the like people
get brutalized in real life women get
brutalized children get ized and the
Joker is a character that will just
cause damage for the sake of damage and
there are people out there that would do
that there are unfortunately people in
our world that are just as insane as the
Joker if you can imagine it it probably
exists somewhere and people don't like
to think these days and that's why
people are complaining they're going oh
my God this made me think of how
terrible our world
is and that's why people are taking
offense oh absolutely absolutely they're
also also mistaking the idea that DC is
endorsing it it's like they didn't put
Batman on the cover doing that they
didn't put Superman on the cover doing
that they put a lunatic on the
cover yeah I mean it's it's a defining
it's a defining trait it was the same
thing with Carol daners if you guys
remember way back when D rapist baby
yeah IM mortise was like I'm going to
like plant my Consciousness in your body
and you're going to give birth to me in
like the main yeah Avers will have no
problem with it yeah yeah it was AV just
go baby crazy yeah and then they're like
oh boy isn't it great you're out to have
a kid uh yeah from an alien who like
took advantage of me what it's they
broke that in later that Carol Dan was
like no I don't want to hang out with
the Avengers you guys were jerks to me
yeah right on by the way good call when
she uh when she gets pulled into the
X-Men when she becomes whatever her name
was in the X-Men binary something binary
that was binary and um she uh she leaves
the X-Men and goes back and like The
Avengers are like hey come back to us
and she was like no no like you guys are
jerks why do you think it was a good
idea that's basically that's like
exactly what happens so I mean I think I
think overall we can go with this stomic
is that basically I mean it's it's a
comic all of us here agree that it
shouldn't have been pulled um if if
anything if anything I think what this
does state is that the internet is going
to latch on to whatever they possibly
can even if they don't fully understand
the what it represents or what is
actually going on they don't understand
that and maybe just hit a day and age
where instead of just being like
wouldn't this be cool look at our
Killing Joke reference DC needs to be
like we can't talk about it anymore my
question is did the art it's like my
thing is like hey the writers didn't
want it DC said they didn't have to have
it did the artists get paid if so then
okay yeah I mean that's it's it's just
it's blindfolded activ activism as all
it is it's one person that says oh my
God look at this and people are like oh
my god let's do something about it but
they have no clue what well it's the
internet and the internet is all about
perception and basically you do
something that DC did it as a you know
oh this is a call back to a great old
story and one person on the internet
started the entire thing with hey guess
what no you can't do that you are
brutalizing women by referencing a story
that is still in the art exchange you're
still selling you know if DC was really
going to make a real stand against what
happened to The Killing Joke it would be
written out of continuity sales would
stop on the book and we would just it
would be literally done but the new 52
launched in one of the first things they
said was hey you recovered from that
whole spinal injury thing right right
hey killing jok still happen though
right yeah we give that back to Alan
Moore right yeah I was going to say I
think we need to all ask Alan Moore
about this what he thinks hey s what
would Alan Moore say if he was here no
the story actually goes that I I wrote
it like over a weekend because I
actually obligated to write like two
more Batman stories it's true he
actually did have to write like he wrote
that like DC said he wanted to get out
of his DC contract and they're like yo
was two more Batman stories one of them
was killing joke he's like all right
well here you go there a story
it just happens to be be crap out of
back girl care that's so amazing is that
he didn't even like he didn't even think
about it and it was and it we're still
talking about it like he really
disregards that book If you ever see him
like talk about it in interviews he's
like who cares whatever well I mean if
you were a guy that wrote a book and
people are just constantly saying like
hey like I know you did really cool
stuff like you did mad Jim Jas and like
you established the Multiverse in like
Marvel Comics but like you did the
killing joke and it's like the only
thing that you're known for and the only
thing you m did this like 18 page book
yeah I would be like look like okay guys
like I don't care it was technically an
elor's comment yeah it was that Liv in
his beard start talking you mean the
birds live there
yeah so okay so I think I think we can
we can we can go with that though at
this point I mean we're we're just at an
age where I mean comic books comic books
are held at a higher regard than they
were back in the day comic books used to
get away with a lot more like they could
do whatever they wanted if they retold
the story of The Killing Joke
today like I mean think just think about
this for one second comic books shoved
Kyle rainer's girlfriend into a fridge
and it started entire movement and they
just didn't think anything about it I
mean what would their demographic is or
anything like they were just like oh
let's just kill this girlfriend that's
fine whatever Just sh the fridge well we
need to we need to make a we need to
make our male protagonist character have
motivation to do something different
let's kill the girl because that's
shocking um my issue is like at the end
of the day for me I it shouldn't be
pulled because it was like
self-censorship censorship General my
issue is like it's put out there it's
out there someone would like the masses
told him to put it away and he did and
that's like for me that sucks cuz
like people are artists are going to
think twice now before producing
something well this isn't even the first
cover that's been pulled they've been
doing it for the last couple of hey look
at our variant cover oh yanked yeah now
that said variant covers maybe maybe
maybe we'll make variants go away
because variants are
dumb
think stance on variant I got it I just
like it's just gouging like it's cool
art like that's awesome but like make a
poster then but don't don't charge $15
for a $3 book hey can we pull some
variants I think are offensive I don't
like Frank Miller's Catwoman variant
that so
terrible I killed Rob I killed can we
pull that that one's offensive to spines
it's offensive to cats proportion and
Anatomy yeah it's the to my brain trying
to understand it all right all right
all go ahead no go ahead F fast go talk
buddy do it I was going to say I find
all the Teen Titans variant offensive
because my comic shop doesn't get any of
them in I should all just be
pulled to end of this variant discussion
I will say this that with the stupidest
variant I ever thought and I only bought
one of them and then I thought what the
hell am I doing is when DC first
launched the new Future 2 they had a
black and white version of every cover
for like $15 yeah and it was the stupid
like yeah let's get it with no cover
like I bought all of
those a nice we that why all right so I
I think I mean we we can rehash the same
topic over and over and over we can talk
about this all day so I think we should
move on to our second topic which is the
massive list on our sign bars here that
we have of books and we will start at
the be I I will go through the list and
you guys can pick one and we'll discuss
it we'll try to keep it under like five
to three minutes per book but if we have
to sit and talk about it three minutes
per book well there like 90 BS there so
like gu say we got to try and keep it
low okay and we said that other topic
wasn't going to take forever that we
thought we would be done quick but it
turned into a thing like if we take the
monarchy of M and talk for 30 minutes
we're going to be here all night talking
about these things that's all right so
once I will be
very all right so get one and then just
start talking yeah I'm looking at the
screen here so TV little house you're
first pick a book and let's discuss what
okay uh wait are we talking about the
canceled books or the continuing books
or or am I let's just pick anything on
this list it's like 90 titles long okay
you know what uh I'm going to just do a
really quick like I'm just gonna knock
off a couple spider Island pass uh
Spider Island's gonna be amazing no why
we saw SP a and that's the end of that
uh Planet H pass uh X cool um what's the
other thing Marvel 1602 she's excited I
am yes I mean
love22 by the way par my question is
Marvel 1602 yes what's 1610 then the
Ultimate Universe eight years later
wa Amer designation for the Ultimate
Universe yes there you go if you go to
marvel.com Secret Wars like they have
616 as a regular Universe I saw that
universe as 1610 if by the way if Marvel
616 is there what's the point well
that's okay but that's the point man is
is they're all like you have all these
different realities converging that's
why you have the Soul Island which has
like Earth 616 and then the Ultimate
Universe and like this tiny little place
for a till yeah a which n yeah nobody
cares you forgot I I all right I'm also
on board for the iamot yes and what is
it the Marvel monsters or whatever
Marvel monsters you're very excited
about yes okay but here's here's my
question renew your vows hooray really
what's Marvel monsters about like
Franken castle Yeah Franken Castle's
coming back yeah it's it's it's kind of
that the right kind of cheese for me
thank you there's a lot cuz Miss
Deadpool is going to be uh what is it
the new Howling Commandos which is Jack
Russell and a bunch of the other Marvel
Chara Deadpool I am so lady to see that
no it's not even Lady it's Miss Deadpool
cuz it's Deadpool's wife who is Queen of
the vampires
andropolis I thought they were bringing
back like Lady Deadpool no no it's it's
it's his actual wife
so it's got to be her now I you know
I've been wanting for a while to see
something about her because it's like he
married Dracula's wife and now she's a
back panel character yeah that's exactly
what
happens had that whole digital series
about her didn't they where they met but
like Marvel digital isn't as good as DC
Digital so you know no one cares Marvel
is a digital they have a digital
line all right well okay so I mean since
you knocked off a whole bunch of them f
what are you looking forward to on the
reboots or the cancellations here oh the
reboots or the cancellations I I I'm
surprised some things are staying and
I'm
surprised actually I'm not surprised
most of the things are being canceled
other than Batgirl but wait Batgirl's
being
cancelled
woman you threw me off like we just
discussed Batgirl and how her new runs
doing this that and the other thing
like don't scare us like that that'll be
the last cover I was like how did I miss
it
like I'm surprised Team Titans is still
going because yeah I love the Titans but
I hate this run
um why look at the team Titans
tweet doing but not good
yeah um and then yeah I just don't enjoy
it and Grayson I'm surprised is still
going because I was under the impression
it's doing really badly should be no
it's actually doing quite well actually
we get a ton of views Grayson every week
actually well then maybe I'll start
doing some Grayson videos every week I
don't know
God you should get them get them Grayson
dollars like dollar I don't have any I
don't have enough videos going up right
now I got one on an 18 hour rotation
that's not enough I need more those
bison dollars like there was no better
scene in that whole movie than when M
bison gave um whatever his name was the
Hitchman guy like paid him in his own
money and he was like this will be the
world's currency and I'm like what okay
I since we're discussing F the why are
they continuing titles let's ask this
one because you're a DC fan as as as I
am and I know everyone here but Rob is
so oh no I'm I'm becoming more of a DC
fan Lobo why is lobo continuing Lobo is
such a lobo is such a sad story because
they gave it to Colin bun who is a great
writer his Indie stuff kicks ass and he
is trying so hard on that book to make
this new Lobo a three-dimensional
character worth caring about but in the
comments of every Lobo video I do people
like it's not old Lobo don't care it's
not
allica so he is literally he is
literally just talking to a brick wall
right now at this series and like
they've Rewritten his whole origin to
where he was The Bodyguard of the
emperor of Zaria and he went all like
Mad King Aries targaryan and he had to
kill the love of his life and he's
fighting to save Earth right now from
assassins who are trying to destroy he's
trying so hard and it's all just on deaf
ears and it's going to be changed
anytime oh yeah he'll be the main man
will be back I mean I have two reasons
for reading the Lobo title number one is
I really kind of like the art and it's
kind of a guilty pleasure title and the
art is so nice and number two the new
Lobo is really [__]
attractive he is he is scrumptious
there's a lot of
came well I mean there there's no other
word I can choose to describe look at
like the a lot of car went into his
design oh for he is he is he is Edward
Cullen meets like Sherlock
Andy tough guys yeah I think so I
haven't seen him oh man well then you
don't watch off the
rack
greato is every six Power Ranger he's
like every know like like angsty bad boy
he's the Green Ranger meets Edward oh my
God man the Green Ranger there was no
better moment in the Power Rangers when
the Green Ranger showed up and like like
you know what guys like I'm the Green
Ranger now and I'm evil and I'm just
going to like beat the hell out of all
of you and he does
it white he's like Tuxedo Mask yeah yeah
oh nice pull nice green ranger is like
The Tuxedo Mask of power rang I know who
a green [__]
R fair enough but um oh my God these are
my co-hosts
yeah we got it going on man yeah we know
what's up okay so that all right so how
about okay continue titles you know you
know it's another one that's that's an
interesting one and maybe you can
discuss we can discuss this one why is
Gotham Academy continuing it's a great
book it's got a good falling it's a good
book what a good book it's
gorgeous and it was kids trying to
escape out of a school and I'm
like it's not my cup of tea but I
respect its fan base and I like that
there's something different on the
shelves and that it's new and it's
original and they unlike the Batgirl
book they didn't do a bunch of ret
conning to make it the way they wanted
it to be dude doesn't threaten anything
you love it's not going to make the
flash go
away no The Flash will make the flash go
away Gotham Academy is just DC's attempt
to anime [__] and as we found out
last week I love anime [__] exactly
it has its place you want Gotham by
midnight then the one about the cops at
night that's justy cop show that Gotham
Academy is like a gateway to anime for
people who haven't been into anime who
were just too afraid to not watch
Batman yeah
I mean Dragon Ball Z got me in anime and
I haven't looked back that gets a lot of
people into anime yeah watching all the
old episodes on TV as they none of this
Kai stuff that the kids have nowadays to
take out all the filler man I was there
when it
happened yes all you kids like who are
watching Dragon Ball Z now and you have
Dragon Ball Z Kai you missed it back in
the day when it's like all right like
we're going to start like trunks is
going to show up and then you start the
whole series over again and it's like no
y we Goku defeat Frieza find out next
time in Frieza
defeated no no no you're talking about
the old school when we were still
getting it translated so we like they
were like like four episodes at a time
and they like now we're going to restart
the whole series because that giv the
time to translate four more let me blow
your mind I'm from Canada we got our own
Dragon Ball Z dub really our ours was
different than yours
yeah I just have these images of Goku
showing up be like so I'm gonna be your
butt down
a I'm really sorry about that
frie Tim Horton you know the UK dubbed
like one of the movies and but it was
like British actors putting on American
accents but then occasionally they'd say
like Mommy instead
[Laughter]
of right back on topic here uh so since
we're going through this one right quick
uh secret 6 I don't even know was still
going already I didn't realiz that that
was secret 6 Is My Jam that is my
religion you leave my girlfriend Gail
Simone tell you something secret 6 is
like TV little Kryptonite we did a whole
episode of off the rack on that we got
like four
views it's it's it's and guess what two
of those guys were me two of those guys
were me how about the the death Str
continuation here's my question for you
cuz Deathstroke and I was looking I was
looking to do the Deathstroke Origins
and Deathstroke has a new origin every
year so
every time they put him in something hey
we're going to retell his entire origin
but we get to make now and he has two
eyes because of TV right oh is he that's
not good oh I didn't I know they brought
they gave him two eyes back here's the
thing he he's young now has two eyes it
changes literally nothing cuz he wears a
face mask that looks exactly the same
wait who's had more Origins Deathstroke
or duet Dent o that's close I'm going to
go with deathro because I think he's
he's more popular than dualist so he
keeps popping
like two or three but I say the problem
with Deathstroke is that every time he
arrives the new writer is like I can
tell a better Deathstroke
origin the book looks beautiful again
it's it's it's uh who is it on Art and
writing he's because he's is it Daniels
I think it's Tony Daniels oh it's Tony
Daniels and it's gorgeous oh it looks
the story is crap but it looks beautiful
and he's TR and he's trying so hard to
to be's like look I'm a bring in his son
Jericho yeah I know Jericho has none of
the connection to the stuff that made
him cool but he's coming in and I'm
bringing in RAV yeah I know she has no
connection to any of the stuff that made
her cool but I'm bringing her and guess
what the villain is his dad adicus and
guess what and guess Deathstroke
inherited his badass assassin skills
because his dad was a badass
assassin it's really dumb it's a really
book but it looks awesome it looks
gorgeous it looks great oh yeah looks so
good so one thing I know she didn't put
here Rob is the new stories that cuz
like we have the list of the Marvel ones
that are coming out afterwards and
during Secret Wars but you didn't put
out the new ones for
like we don't have that like we don't
have that list of what they're going to
be doing after Secret Wars do we yeah
they've come out they solicited it yeah
yeah
well what was the list like I didn't
realize they had a list we also have the
list of books that are happening during
convergence like Catwoman's gonna fight
off against Kingdom Come Batman all the
flashes are going to meet up on one big
like speed force yeah speed force F okay
Team
Titans the list that I sent excited for
those the list I sent you guys were the
titles that they were they were going to
be continuing or relaunching after
convergence and the ones that were
killing off but that that was the most
updated information I had actually
didn't realize I mean I guess it makes
sense they did it like this week the
actual list of the post okay it was like
that later it was like 15 new books but
again it's like even the books that
they're canc like you're not really
cancelling these you're just retitling
them and having them come back out all
right which is what I was going to
mention next Jo we have a list here of
all the books that are being canceled
for post cuz we already know that that
Marvel is pretty much canceling
everything so that that's pretty so they
can make everything number one again
yeah everything's going be number one so
everything's either getting a reboot or
a total cancellation DC is currently got
continuing and rebooted continuing and
re officially titled as a reboot are
Action Comics Aquaman Batgirl Batman
Detective Comics Batman Superman
Catwoman Deathstroke The Flash Gotham
Academy Gotham by midnight Grayson Green
Arrow Green Lantern Harley Quinn Justice
League Lobo secret six Sinestro new
Suicide Squad Superman Superman Wonder
Woman Teen Titans I'm sorry that should
be the new Teen Titans
wonder wonder woman uh Justice League
United why is that one going don't for
oh I was so disappointed by the last
issue of that I'm just like you know
what this can go away now ship on
Justice League United when it became
Justice League United instead of Justice
League of America Justice League of
America went like seven issues and they
were like oh wow we're like alienating
the entire rest of the world cancel
reboot then it got then it got lost in
tie-ins even though Jeff Johns did
really good on it and now we're getting
a new Justice League of America which is
just the main regular Justice League so
we're going to have two now okay cancel
titles are Arkham Manor which makes
sense because that is a story arc that
is going to end I love it is it canceled
or is just ending it just it was a five
isue miniseries this like some of this
information like these books didn't end
they just reached the end of their run
they
were oh Batman Robin is becoming Daman
what would you say was Damen Son of
Batman Daman son of which is fine
because Daman is super Powers right now
and they don't look like they're going
anywhere so we're going to see where
that pans out yeah batwoman's gone but
she's I don't know batwoman's gone
through hell for four years so she gave
a valiant
fight away and I can tell you exactly
why Constantine's going away they don't
need it anymore the show got back as
constan hellblazer though but it's
coming back as Constantine hellblazer no
what I'm saying though is it's coming
back as constan and I think it's going
back to vertigo also oh yeah so they're
basically going look all right this this
whole familyfriendly Constantine didn't
work
leav his trench code in the DC Universe
yeah what's up with that like and he got
a new costume no more trench code like
he's not wearing a costume he was
wearing the clothes he slept in for the
last six years I say it's not a costume
he just got hot and took his coat off
well maybe Eric Larsson got upset that
he had too many layers
on Le like didn't take off the coat and
reveal spandex
yes entire com out of by the entire time
he's got like his spanic [__] with a Big
C y constan well that's how they're
going to actually Rebrand the comic so
the TV show can get renewed see it's all
smart
marketing yeah shows are saved by Comic
Book Sales well uh Earth 2 is being
canceled and anybody who's been reading
Earth 2 knows that that book that book
was done at issue 31 it's still going
I've been enjoy it but it's coming back
as Earth to society so they're just
going to be the Society of superheroes
now well and I I love they just push it
into the regular universe and move on to
fill the rules everyone who wasn't
already there yeah no I I love I do love
Earth to and I do love what they're
doing with World's End and everything
but like look I anybody else been
reading can go ahead and vou with this
they've been dragging on the destruction
of Earth 2 now for like the last months
like the blade is on fire dark siiz
we're
done exactly the fact that it's already
spoiled because we know in Futures End
who made it and who didn't make it to
main earth right but you know what
people hate Futures ends so maybe those
change it it's true I know I hate it I'm
amazed I'm still reviewing it every week
I 35 but F you have a right with Earth
two is just blow up so yeah that's it
blowing up finally end it yeah Green
Lantern core is just becoming Green
Lantern lost
lanterns yeah okay uh justice league
dark you guys said is getting a reboot
as dark
society which is a weird title because
it's related to that deloro movie that
may never get made but they're going to
call the comic dark Universe now what
maybe it's just because it frauds Del
Tor a little bit like
Hey we're still supporting you every
movie makes like every third movie like
he doesn't like every time Del torus is
like I'm gonna make a movie like you're
like okay well we'll see the reason I
hope this Del Toro movie gets made is
because I'm a big thing like costuming
is a big thing for me like I'm a
cosplayer I love costumes I love fashion
Del Toro gets cosplayers in to help on
the movies costumes yeah that's really
smart does he really yeah oh yeah yeah
he's been meaning to do the uh that that
uh Lovecraft movie into the mouth of
Madness or whatever mountains of Madness
he's been trying to make forever and no
one will let him it's never gonna happen
Del Toro just
stop yeah anyway well so the next one on
the list here this is I think the
funniest rebranding Justice League 3000
is becoming Justice League 31 am is not
being called Justice League we're not
doing that anymore yeah it's like it's
like not even trying like it is fun by
the way it's a fun fun series I love de
Matas but yeah 3001 he was like I
remember you made that announce he was
like yeah it's going to be canceled but
I will be but you should pick up my new
series Justice Le
3001 what does that mean like after like
we're going to do another 12ish Arc and
then be 3002 3003 that would not if it
lasted that long I bet they would do it
you think one time he accidentally wrote
3,001 instead of 3,000 and just went
genius yeah
now they're gonna have to take it yeah
um yeah and F knows more about this one
clarion's getting canceled it's
terrible Clarion it's terrible when that
book came out I'm like this is gonna
make it six issues and it made it
exactly six issues when it came out I
was like okay the Art's good maybe that
will push it through and then I started
reading it and I was like oh my God this
is so bad and it just kept reading and
issue two came out like it got worse how
did it get worse it's also not even the
real Clarion it's a Clarion From Another
Dimension who is not the Clarion we saw
in the Futures End time because that was
a Clarion from Earth to and it turns out
the Clarion from witch world and the
Clarion from limbo town are two
different Clarens as well so there's
lots of Clarens running
about but they're all witch boys that
that's all that matters now you guys
know I'm not a big big two reader so
when you posted the list of things were
getting canceled there were certain
titles that jumped out of me I was like
I don't know what that is so that's not
a surprise Clarion was one of them the
next one on the list was one of them in
the forever people y I was like what the
hell is this I remember them announcing
that one and they were like we're doing
Infinity man in the forever people and
I'm like that like like you said that
will make it six issues that it God
bless them there here based on title I
was like that doesn't surprise me even
in the slightest and I don't know a damn
thing about it see I was sad that INF
Infinity man and the forever people
didn't do better because I was like and
they might stop bringing back forth well
titles and then they might do that fifth
world thing they tried attempting they
could do a full series on the super
young team no one remembers them other
than me we can dream man we can dream um
red hood of the Outlaws is getting can
good yeah no not red hood anything but
red hood oh no not that great character
this is that one comic that I personally
will read when I'm angry so I can a
review and just rip it apart
I but it's getting reched Red Hood and
Arsenal yeah just the boys now it's just
Red Hood and Arsenal and Starfire is
getting her own title yeah Starfire is
getting her own book um Red Lanterns is
cancelling uh I've been reading this
since the beginning and I can tell you
right now that story's been done for the
last 10 issues
like we need like ever like the last
great Arc for that one was Guy Gardner
and then they ended it like and they
ended it on like a really solid note
like he beat a TR it was over he held on
to the ring he went back to Earth and
then it's like and now we have more and
now we have more and now it's like just
just stop just stop the comment amazed
they made it that many issues
too like like the last issue right now
was him dealing with a baby who is the
embodiment of rage and now apparently
he's going on a CrossCountry exploration
adventure with the baby on his back oh
my God that sounds like the most amazing
story ever like say like DC knows that
if you take your character that usually
can fly and have him just walk across
the country you're pretty much
guaranteed safe goes so well every time
always not look up the latest issue the
latest issue there was a baby who was
the embodiment of Rage after like
everything happened at by F
died that rage baby it's a it's a rage
baby basically and like it ends with
like oh this baby has no family because
he killed his own family but he's just a
baby and he doesn't understand his
powers so like he straps him to his back
and you just see him walk in the highway
like the an incredible like Lone Wolf
and Cub
guy walk for the baby I'm like what is
going on with this so that's not a
surprise um secret Origins I think
honestly in my opinion is ending because
they've run out of Origins yeah they've
done everyone even vaguely interested
this worries me because how are they
going to Recon Tim Drake every five
months yeah well I think the bigger
question here is why would anybody want
them to Recon Tim Tim Drake every five
months well no none of us want that keep
doing it well I want them to do it until
he has the title of like at least had
the title of just then even if it was
just for a week just for an hour that's
all I want eventually they'll just they
it'll just go full circle like they'll
just be like hey wouldn't it be cool if
he was like Batman's partner he was
Robin we we haven't done that yet
huh you know the worst part about secret
Origins is the latest issue they're not
even doing the origins of people we care
about anymore they they did the origin
of the of the girl inside of the
computer version of Batgirl I know right
and that's actually an important issue
because it's like hey guys you should
really go read this because we're retcon
and big stuff so yeah yeah but but like
like it's like oh we're going to do an
origin you may care about An Origin you
might care about oh and and An Origin
you didn't even know existed here's the
origin of Oracle in the new 52 but we're
not calling her Oracle like
what um um star spangled War Stories is
that n it's about zombie oh yes it's
about GI zombie I championed the [__]
out of this book Paul miotti is my man
he has been trying so hard to bring back
War comic since the beginning of New 52
and across the board everyone's like
nope not
happening that book was actually a
really it didn't feel like a DC book it
felt like an image book like this is an
image pitch palotti had laying around in
D's like
yoink I'd be surprised um I'm a little
shocked on this one Supergirls
cancelling I've actually been enjoying
it up until the end of the Red Lantern
Arc and then they were like now we're
bringing her to Hogwarts I'm not even
joking
she's in a school in space where they
teach you how to use their powers and I
saw the interview DC entertainment did
with the writer and she's like I wanted
to bring hog warts to Supergirls I read
that that's
Dum if they wanted to do that they
should just have her join Gotham
Academy just have her Joy just have her
make a new Young Justice team hey I like
that isn't she coming back in something
else like when the show comes out
they'll have a new there you go probably
Supergirl or something so so they're
probably just separating Supergirl from
her current Hogwarts Academy armor that
did not that did not catch so they were
like right I give it a year there'll be
another Supergirl tit to year no I was
saying at the end of this year I think
is the Supergirl show so that'll be
something you
yeah out of the Swamp Thing is ending
and like three people in the world cried
yeah our Buddy Joe cried man and again
the early arcs of that are great when it
was uh until World up until yeah I mean
like I I'm still going to collect it in
trade I mean what's I'm sad about this
is the when the new 52 start like yeah
the red and the green these are going to
be big integral Concepts to this new
universe and then they're like oh well
cancel animal man now I guess a swamp
things gone to ah forget the red and the
green whatever the red and the green
even like bled over into the Teen Titans
they had Beast Boy red in the Teen
Titans so he was connected to the red
and now he's green now he's just green
with no
explanation it's so frustrating Earth
two has done more with the red and the
green ideology than the main Universe
ever did but Earth ch's running run with
that was amazing like that's one of and
it's funny cuz no one will ever know it
because it's it's like tied into the
World's End side of the story which who
cares yeah so it's like you read it like
three pages of the avatars you might
have to care for convergence I keep
waiting to write my quick guide to
convergence I'm like neither of these
stories are done yet and I don't even
know what to write yet like
when they said they wanted the red and
the green to be really integral to the
universe I said they're going to do a
red and green title and each issue we're
going to focus on another character that
utilizes the red or the green it never
happened yep well the next thing on the
list here is the Trinity of sin which I
think is the most under underutilized
thing okay so just you know what the
Trinity of sin is the DC Universe
started Pandora opened up and she was
like it's a great mystical thing coming
out blah blah blah they started really
touching on the supernatural we had
people touching in everything was going
crazy Pandora was popping up saying as
Pandora's Box Supernatural Supernatural
Mystic Mystic Supernatural Mystic Mystic
and then it's like nope it's a gateway
to Forever Evil it was it was a boom
tube it this whole TR this whole for or
Trinity event was just a lead into
forever evil right it was just it was a
boom tube for the crime syndicate and
then we'll build up the question was
like oh who is this new mysterious
question he's not Vick Sage yeah we
don't even know who he is who cares well
so what ended up happening with that and
this is where the Trinity sin came from
I I think happened was they were going
mystical and they Abandoned Ship last
second oh yeah the Trinity of sin is the
continuation of what the hell actually
happened with Pandora's Box and I
started reading it at the beginning and
it started okay and then it just was
like where the hell is this going it's
the Pandora and question and phanom
stranger fighting against the odds and
whatever well they did the same thing
when they switch when they switched over
the tone for Wonder Woman when like the
like aella was Wonder Woman was all like
mystical well not mystical but like you
know it was it was steeped in mythology
and then they turned around and now it's
the finches and it's like oh my God like
remember Phantom stranger when that book
starts like written by Dan Deo I just
imagine that was sitting on the desk
it's like what does no one want this
book fine then all right Phantom
stranger
then and then he was Judas the whole
time I am a
genius um but yeah so that's ending
world's finest that technically ended
like 10 issues ago but the somehow it's
still going it got lost in the Earth 2
Shuffle which is it's going to make it
really hard for people who want to get
the whole Earth 2 story because you're
going to have to read Earth 2 world Zen
this for the backstory and you're also
going to need to read a couple issues of
Batman Superman which are also origin
stories for the Earth two versions of
those
characters um and then and the only one
of us here who's going to cry about this
Aquaman and the
others is it actually call it Aquaman
and the
other the G Island cast like and the
rest yeah it's aqu and the rest that was
their name and here's the thing I I'm
going to have a reason for that to cry
too the like the last issue of this came
out just recently and arm and I were set
to review it because we'd actually
really been joyed they had done some
good arcs before with the atlantan
artifacts they fought like this uh kg
Beast they brought him back and he had a
whole team oh great yeah I know right
yeah I know I'm excited for kg I am to
be killing you now was fantastic this
was back when Putin was acting a fool
and we thought that the Russians could
be evil scary bad guys again like a
minute back yeah yeah that final issue
of that was just like oh wow you you
knew you were getting cancelled didn't
you you just like yeah and then it's
over right my whole thing with Aquaman
and the others is that it's just not
campy enough to be an Aquaman book The
Art was not great either for my no they
were I like the operative I liked
prisoner of war I liked all the people
on his team I we have one question and
it falls in what you had said joelan one
fall before we move into the Marvel side
of the house um someone asked where's Dr
Fate well if you read like The as Joel
said the 50 gajillion things for Earth
to he is there and he's doing stuff but
the new Dr Fate they're getting who's
going to have a solo series is not earth
two Dr fade it's not khed it's gonna be
someone different but it's also not Kent
Nelson so it's gonna be someone
else it'll be Rene name on to you oh
she's coming back in Detective Comics so
good she's great she is okay so oh we're
running the long time guys we got to
move on we have another 30 something
books to go through so you're the one
who's reading the this list all right so
now now we're going to get to the weird
we're going to get to what's happening
over at Marvel secret wars during the
secret Wars so we've got two Incredible
Hulks we've got Greenland now I'm going
to name off their locations what they're
named on Battle world and what's
happening there and I just want everyone
to give me their their responses to
these just like we just did don't have a
give give Thumbs
Up Everybody Do you realize that if we
would spent all that time on DC and then
just thumbs up thumbs down Marvel the
Marvel fan base will kill us the Marvel
fan base will understand they're doing
the same
thing yeah all right all right okay fine
Greenland which is going to feature the
planet Hulk results you know what I do
like the idea of Captain America riding
a dinosaur in
there I'm a Hulk junk you sign me up
yeah here dystopia is where future and
perfect is they've been building up to
this story Peter David has been trying
really hard to tell a new story with the
m and everything else I hope it connects
with everything but it probably won't
buty I wonder how uh Peter David felt
about Bendis using the
Maestro yeah I bet he didn't read it but
if he did i' bet he'd be really mad
probably um the domain of Apocalypse
will house the My Little
Ponies oh
yeah
uh domain of Apocalypse is where the Age
of Apocalypse is go huh yeah no let it
die I'm so burned out on let them die
hey Rob yeah me
too what's the status on Asian
apocalypse
Rob I've been talking to chat about
pudding man I have no idea where you
guys are talking about he's right it
right now hang on we we just been
talking about pudding like all this
time here's the stupidest apocalypse is
not going to get finished okay you know
what Age of Apocalypse hasn't been
relevant since like the 6 months after
it ended
it's coming back yeah it is coming back
yes I one handed
Logan SOC but see see here was here was
the funny thing like like blink was a
character who didn't matter like she
showed up and was almost immediately
killed when she first appeared yeah and
then they were like you know what like
let's bring her back for the Age of
Apocalypse like she's she's like this
strong independent chick that don't need
no man and like fans were like she's
amazing and they brought her back we do
our sliders Sor the thing is that's not
even the 616 blink and then I made a
history of blink that was about the 616
blink and now I get like at least one
comment every other day that says what
about Age of Apocalypse what about Age
of Apocalypse when are you going to do
the Age of Apocalypse yeah I'll do the
age of seconds in that new X-Men movie
she got 10 whole seconds to jump around
pretty
good but here's the
thing the other thing you guys have to
remember too is like a lot of these
stories that we're getting are going to
be rewrites of exist existing stories
yeah they're not actually going to be
the thing so like the age of apocalpse
Rees well they're supposed to be at
least as far as I understand I mean was
a new story well it is a new story well
we don't know as far as as far as I
understand it see this is this is why
it's such a pain from what I understood
from what bort was saying during their
meeting during their conference which
was a ridiculous thing that conference
was me and cell Che why did you just
like like they they were like we got
this dry race marker board up here we're
at the Town Comics it's like there's a
customers walking back and forth yeah
like what are you doing you have you
have like you made the top three tiest
grossing movies of the year and you
can't like spring for a conference
room that's what we inside we're saying
we were like did they even like try was
there even any like concern or were they
just like you know let's just like make
an announcement throw it out there and
the hell with it like three like
freelance staffers for CBR who are like
woo go to the Elks club is what you
should do go to God but had trophies as
far as I understood it from the meeting
that that briard had from that whole
video thing is the stories that they're
giving us during Secret Wars so like The
Infinity Gauntlet which is new xandar
stuff like that it's just going to be
like a retelling of those stories like
it's going to be totally different so
seen because I thought it was going to
be a continuation of those stories well
some of them are like Theory happened
and then like what if they didn't have
to worry about continuity and they just
kept going that's that's what be doing
with some of like that's why some of
those it's a retelling of stories that
happen so like age of ulton would be
retold find out happened I mean that was
that was the question like it's supposed
to be a didn't like how it ended I I
thought it was going to be what if we
threw this aspect of this story Into the
mix of this story yeah well see like
here here thing like you guys have to
remember like DC or Marvel came out and
they they told us how time works like
they said like it's Ranch universe
theory anytime an alternate reality
comes into existence by the actions of a
person it's a totally separate Universe
now they established that with Days of
Future Past so what they're doing I
think is they're doing a mishmash of
things Age of Apocalypse I think is
either going to be a retelling or
continuing of that Universe because
remember that Universe never ended like
it's still going um the Days of Future
Past I think is going to be a rewrite
but that universe is still going which
is kind of weird um The Age of Ultron
Universe never ended wolver rain just
went back in time and stopped himself
killing Hank Pim which whatever whatever
Bendis what the [__] were you thinking
and then
like he stabbed himself man coolest
thing ever I don't man Bendis I don't
know I don't know what Bendis was
thinking when he did that it was Bendis
being Bendis I guess but um Bendis is
gonna Bend so um but like Old Man Logan
like that universe is still going so
you're going ahead of the list man we
got a
list
let's discuss egyptia egypti new y the
new Warriors who wanted to see the
Warriors go on everyone's favorite the
new Warriors love the new Warriors which
which one is it going to be is it going
to be the one with speedball a night
Thrasher and
dark like speedball and namorita and let
let me tell Scarlet Spider all right so
I think we've established that how about
technopolis that works too I I give that
a thumbs up because I'm actually way
back into Iron Man now like I never have
been before I'm digging the superior run
and my big question is just like how
come his brother Arno isn't stopping him
and then for this new armor War it's
just going to be like oh it's him and
his brother fighting each other I'm like
good co okay that answer my question
yeah that's number six is currently
classified so let's throw a thousand one
wild speculations my thought is that
this is where the ti Min internals are
going to fight with the Ghostbusters and
they're all going to come together to
fight against friendship is magic so no
I think there going be it's renew your
vows no V is already established it's
not on this list it's the runway the
runway title isn't on this list
either they keep adding new titles is
the thing well no like like Marvel like
marvel.com
secet Wars whatever it is has like has
their list as of right now but renew
your valves is already established as a
own Universe um I think that one's going
to be Marvel Zombies because Age of
Ultron is a own Universe you have the
Marvel Zombies versus Age of Ultron
Universe yeah so I don't know I don't
know all right number seven is spider
Island the Amazing Spider-Man spider
Island don't care I the only who likes
spider Island I love I love that story
and then it
ended my only question is will it have
Madame web in it if it does I'll care
which
one any any of he just wants the brought
back The Young Madam web again at the
end of spiders she wakes up out of the
coma that's right she came back just
recently I didn't read spider bu now
I've got to read it now you got it
all you got to read is the last last
like epilog book and you're fine yeah
like the last couple p apparently was
all supposed to Star superior Spider-Man
and he had and Dan sloted to rewrite the
whole damn thing right yeah Dan came out
with an interview side note here about
about spiderverse that was supposed to
where just be the arc between 17 to 24
and that was it just a superior
Spider-Man story and I guess the editor
decided no you can't do that you can't
do something like this and not have it
about you about Peter Parker yep so
we're gonna so he had to shoehorn in the
the story arc where 200 99 showing up in
our time period and he had to shoehorn
in the story of superior venom yep and
that's that's how that all came out of
it spiderverse wasn't even intended like
a year ago no anyway what's up next uh
Regency in the clone saga so that's the
wedding that's that's that's the renew
your vows yeah okay okay clones um so we
have King James England MTI 6 Marvel
6 y got a lot of in the house and they
do uh Neil G owes them a couple of books
so maybe we'll make two sales at least
from this conversation will which I
don't understand I don't get why they're
writing this story like didn't like the
1602 Universe like blow up no or
something like that no I never read it's
great we know for sure if they do get
Neil gaming in to do this we'll get
sometime next
year I'll wait it's worth it I can
wait sense his eternals was kind of weak
shut
up all right next book on the list is
weird world which is weird world does
anyone know what that is no it's weird
chat no do what don't you have the
battle map
openap open you know you know what this
is weird world has put on this list
solely to stump People Like Us where
it's like ah you YouTube people think
you're so smart Comics
channels we'll show you
um okay klao is [__] Kon is getting wait
Kon gets his own location yes yeah well
it's AAL realm and it's weird the way
they're doing it like okay imagine the
House of M with karate like that's what
it's going to be basic all the martial
arts characters are going to be there
and they're going to be like anybody who
doesn't study karate is like a lesser
past in society yeah hey Sean got a book
for you to
review all yours buddy it's all
yours um you
Udo what the sorry world world stories
uh which were sort of like Marvel's
versions of tolken Lord of the Rings oh
what oh wait till you get to kill cven
man it's good thing was absolute garbage
well that's com up too that's in here uh
yeah utopolis Squadron Sinister bad
Sinister yes the Squadron Sinister was a
stupid freaking book that was that was
Hyperion first appearing in Marvel
Comics I think and grandmas was like I'm
going to form this team and like he
sends them to fight The Avengers I think
and it's stupid like I swear some of
these titles it feels like they just
blindfold and like okay we're going to
make secret War tying about uh Squadron
Supreme okay right it's like it's like
Marvel Comics like you have an infinite
number of universes that you could just
make you could just say well this
universe is always been there it's just
we're just now seeing it like you you
have all these options and we get like
the squad
Sinister like really old school with a
bunch of these too maybe they were doing
it as on purpose they're like if this
sells like Gang Busters we're going to
do something no one's going to no one
cares about Squadron Sinister the only
person the only person on that team
anybody cares about his Hyperion it's
only because he's part of the new
Avengers now we're part of the Avengers
okay all right we gotta keep moving
we're running really long time here all
right so we got new Mars with kill Raven
go no yes kill Ren okay all right hire
Avalon with the captain written core I'm
down with that I'm I'm cool with that
okay the arachnia the spiderverse event
continuing don't care are me and I
reviewed it so we're going to review
that too Spider-Man does great for us
and they definitely teased at the end of
spiderverse like hey want to come back
and see what happens
next no no I don't want to see what
happen rville Avengers versus X-men
namely The Avengers babies and X babies
one
shot okay that sounds fun that actually
sounds pretty fun I mean that's
obviously going to be like their their
child lineup you know they're going to
be targeting towards kids but that's a
great
idea made it super sick aoto catch the
doctor strange fever now well he can
he's getting the movie I don't
understand I don't understand what the
purpose of iamamoto is supposed to be I
guess it'll just be a realm of magic I
mean is this gonna be like the Cent
Market and like every just like Doctor
Strange is that gonna be it I don't get
it what's wrong with that I didn't say
anything was wrong with that I
understand what they're going to do with
that
un also got uh currently classified okay
we got a bunch of Manhattans so we got
616 Universe Ultimate Universe Marvel
metropolitans with Mrs Deadpool and the
H Commandos monster Metropolis that's
Franken castle and man
thing I'm trying to read it in a hurry
my brain's not working right I'm so
burned out from today oh man U we also
have a tillan the Inhumans apparently
are just gonna be like this whole battle
worlding overhead like hey guys what's
going on yeah they're yeah they're on
their little island they can go to the
moon and nobody cares with them um the C
would
really good under Char soul I haven't
read it I don't care about the inum I
don't care my God we have so many more
to go you better care CU they're on
shield and they're going to be in movies
you I
know in a minute yeah but like in human
inum trash do what now we
continuing we have what we have new
quack City with Howard Duck we have the
Far East where the monsters
dwell yeah there's more
monsters dinosaurs and and no that's the
valley of flame with devil dinosur no
I'm telling you it says Phantom Eagles
back in his own rip raring Adventure
World War I Aviation Ace Carl Coffman
collides with Prehistoric Beasts in
where monsters dwell fighters fighter
planes dinosaurs and history lessons you
won't soon forget yeah and you know you
know who cares like you know all the
people
who nobody nobody cares it's like a very
big zero amount of people that car but
is writing it though
Who who okay no what I think I think
he's the
lagy uh Hydra and there's a Hydra world
and there's a Marvel 2099 World
y there's Captain Marvel in the Carol
core what yes Captain Marvel in the
Carol core interesting I didn't know
there were more than one carols I
thought it was just her no the Carol
core uh way way there's multip four and
multiple hulks yeah the Carol cor Way
Way Back were what fans of Carol D used
to call themselves um but I think this
is going to be like a World War II Carol
core where there's lots of carols or
it's like a team of girls that are
inspired by Carol or something okay all
right I mean it sounds like it sounds
like Marvel's answer to we are Robin
from converion yeah that's weird yeah
it's interesting okay monarchy monarchy
monarchy of M why can't I talk from the
House of M Universe yeah I guess it'll
be like at the house of universe never
exist never ended which I don't
understand how you could do that because
it did end no but like but didn't rob
you see what what see how easy that was
what if she
didn't while doing house yeah yeah I I
guess I mean see that sounds like a what
if story like what if the what stories I
know what if un was was a what if title
I get that I'm saying like senal
territories Xmen oh did I interrupt Rob
I don't think I've done it enough yeah
you interrupted me you and your hair
interrupted me
man I'm telling you when I get done with
this it's going to be better than F all
right
you can
try you can try you will fail we got
sunel territories Days of Future Past we
have the wastelands with Wolverine Old
Man Logan mutopia Grant Morrison's new
X-Men yes I I'm so excited about that
one Westchester the X-Men 92 yes yes I'm
really excited about that why don't they
just making it about the cartoon Caron
just take Jim Lee's X-Men and then just
make them the X-Men no because it needs
to be about the cartoon Jim Lee had us
rendering the
no no no but like who cares that that
cartoon that cartoon is by the way oh my
god really quick on the reddits there
was oh sorry Joel go ahead don't think
that's how it's worded but okay on the
reddits no I I hope this X-Men thing is
so popular that that DC is like hey we
should do a Batman 92 now because Marvel
X be so great be called Batman
adventures CU that's what it was called
in the
coms and we next up on the list we have
the greatest com ever exist oh my god
really Benny you're going to cut off S
we can spare we can spare an extra 10
minutes s he got that's funny all right
modok assassin pass no one cares about a
floating guy who poops himself but but
he's in
kville by the way best Earth making him
into a
throne I guess with the a force bar
Sinister with X-Men mutant Massacre
Limbo with X-Men Inferno the Dead with
Marvel of
zombies uh Perfection with Age of
Ultron new Xander with The Infinity
Gauntlet and the wall where the shield
lies what does that even mean they're on
the wall is it is it like the wall like
like it's like the wall from like Game
of Thrones like like all the I see that
it's more like an equator no it's a wall
Richard Ryder is being sent off to wear
the black I don't know like like from
imagination land it's like a wall that
they're going to put wallpaper on and
that's just going to be the
like the Great Wall
Shinall that would be div
wall I want to see scw the wall this is
going to look really dumb until it busts
out because if there's a real wall if
there's a literal wall it's a literal W
that separates universes does that mean
that like if one Universe makes a really
big tower you can see it from another
univer like this is really stupid great
CH yeah that's exactly what I'm thinking
of it maybe maybe it's like a like a
techn like a technological wall like
some sort of like like this barrier I I
can you like so you could like you got
me like Source wall I know what the
source wall is but like this
hypothetical no all right anyway maybe
it's like that's it I fit the end you
guys maybe it's a wall made out of
decoys maybe it's the wall where I buy
music in the 90s no maybe maybe it's
literally like the wall does anyone else
remember newberry's Comics just
yes there ads
yeah um oh so really quick my my story
about the reddits regarding X-Men
92 the on R/C comic book some like
somebody posted the the preview for XMen
92 top comment was something like
um am I excited about this does a mle
baby eat chili fries there and then the
top comment response was I don't know
you guys no more for beast on the cover
I'm as nervous as a longtail cat in a
room full of rocking chairs oh yes the
next comment was this one's for you more
abandoned subtlety
and do we quotes this one for un I go
where I want to go I was like thank you
I'm just happy they're doing that
instead of something that's inspired by
the movies X-Men because I can't stand
Rogue in the movie because she's just so
much like I don't want to use my Powers
Yeah I I just want regular fireworks
Jubilee back for Fourth of ju yeah like
I just want to see I want to like read a
comic where they just throw out like
X-Men the Animated Series CL I want to
see Wolverine and saber-tooth fighting
each other and wolver Reign like like he
knocks him down he's on top of him and
he like bust out his claws he's like
let's see what you had for
breakfast know if you want if you want
the cartoon series version of them he
won't actually use the exactly every he
will he will make an empty threat with
his claws in every single episode and
then be thwarted from using them well no
no see what they're going to do is
they're going to fix that like he's
going to use his claw because it's the
because it's the comic book it's the
comic book I'm just happy that the X-Men
92 series is coming because Jubilee's in
it one of my favorite X-Men and and
dazla is actually in that Universe She
was like in an episode for like 10
minutes okay all there even X Factor
with strong guy in wolves Baner is in
that Universe dude me and F had this
conversation like like a week ago and we
were talking we were talking for like 10
minutes of f was like oh I'm so glad
dazzler is coming back I'm like well
you're like the one person I will tell
you I liked playing as dazzler in the
old X-Men's freestanding arcade game
yeah that's true that was fun but she
could like make flashes of light and and
she was like a Herald once
yeah I
guess don't forget don't forget that
right now she's currently possessed by a
demon or something like that and working
for shield and she's also traveling
she's also traveling through time with
an afro wearing Deadpool to kill z uh
vampires back in the 1970s that's a
couple ago now now she's not nearly as
interesting she's back now but now she
just has a horrible costume that no one
pays any attention to like her character
she looks weirdly like comic book L9 now
and it
makes I bet you know that's deliberate
you know that's deliberate okay you want
to talk about B girl 19 Spider-Man 2099
his landlord is just comic book girl 19
yeah it is that's what that had to be
because when are we going to be in com
un that's what I want to know like like
I just I just want like I just want to
be in a comic book I just want to be a
guy where like Spider-Man is like like
swinging you know or something like that
and he was he looks down he's like
what's that guy doing and like I'm just
sitting there with my vape pan and I'm
just like man
just we just hanging out somewhere yeah
you can't be vaping man no there's no
smoking in it's not smoking man it's
vaping God man you know all they need to
do is have have a have one issue with a
panel where they walk past and it's just
me and F arguing about
hair or or or they could have like
Spider-Man on his computer watching like
the weekly po
pod maybe we're already maybe we're
already in the comics and whenever we
say oh God look at that [__] that's
us Rob your idea of smoking like what's
what's cooler looking Wolverine w like
bursting through the door with a big
stoy or Wolverine bur
going way of the future man vaping is
the way of the future he's way future
man man you guys let's just chill out
for like I'm I'm going with the vaping
he looks now Joel's been trying to say
something this whole time but he's I was
gonna say you're talking about appearing
in comics I got so needlessly giddy this
week in Superior Iron Man because he's
selling a weapon to a general daily and
he actually spells it the way I spelled
my last name and I'm like oh for a
second it's like Iron Man knew my
name yeah well try having a name like S
without being a having it be a mobster
that Batman punches in the face it's
true I mean with the name like fa I mean
there's Felix F but I don't think that
counts for me DR Strange met F in hell
at some
point and you get like Dr f is the
Captain America villain so yeah oh yeah
yeah I'm just everywhere in don't worry
my name's Benny I either get Benny Hill
or Benny in the jet it's the only joke
and when they find out my last name is
Potter it's every Harry Potter joke no
mankind comes out and the Jets there it
is at least you got a good song you got
a good song what do you
got nothing
nothing I guess that's it yeah I guess
that's it I guess we're GNA end it on
that one now now we should all end it
with a roundabout song as an an exit now
it's going to be like madli so we'll
each say one word all right right oh so
we're going to do this we're all going
to say one word as a signed out all
right so this is going to be disastrous
or it's going to be hilarious it might
be both s you have to kick it off go s
say something kick it off wait a song No
we're gonna mad Li an EG an outro like
okay thanks
F
help
Armes
PlayStation
Rob I have no idea what I'm supposed to
do just say a word yes uh
peace I don't know
Joel okay so we just
got I'm doing the full one thanks help
PlayStation what peace naal what kind of
a sign sound off is that it's an awesome
sound going someone should make like a
little jingle with that with a cassier
keyboard oh God you know somebody's
going to autotune
this
play thanks help PlayStation peace
napom all right so thank you guys so
much for joining us today um we're way
over time we tried our best we hope we
we hope you guys enjoyed this with us
staying a little more on topic and
having a little more Focus let us know
at the weekly poll. net what you thought
of today's episode go to the forums and
you'll see a little Forum bracket there
the weekly poll go on on there and let
us know what you thought about today's
episode and about us having everyone on
here we know we had a lot of people on
here and I know our meanies was sitting
there plotting everyone's death cuz he
didn't say very much but this really
worked out though yeah I worked out
pretty well other than F being blackb
for the first 20 minutes but I was
trying to say stuff if you watch back
the video I kept
going yeah like bin binnie has a way of
just like not letting you get a word I
wasn't even sing you just going nuts hey
you invited me on specifically for that
if I don't talk about it that makes you
guys look like [__]
I'm fine with it but I'm just saying
that Rob cannot put that on that that
for that 20 minutes it was not me I was
sitting here just like all right well
let's keep going if we can just have a
dedicated podcast about Aquaman I'll
never shut the hell up so true true
we'll have that next time all right guys
that's s and Tiffany from TV little
house go check them out for daily on the
like on the couch discussions about
comic books that is f from his super
effective he does history of videos and
he does his own like unique brand what
do you do other than history of
like is who's this what's your name
Felix
what I do stuff like sexuality and
comics and I explain who the hell people
are I don't even know why I forgot about
that because that's actually the video
that I saw first on your channel but
whatever he does a lot of explanations
about comic books and stuff like that
that is armen's and Joel of comic book
cast they bring you a video every day as
a matter of fact they bring you like 10
every day they will explain everything
in existence that involves the word
comic book in it true that is raw from
Comics plain if you don't know who he is
what are you doing on this channel what
you doing here you just stumble in
and I'm Benny the comic story and you
can go check out my stuff for
dramatically read Comics very soon we're
going to be popping this over at hit
boox you'll find us over there and don't
forget about the weekly pool.net that is
our community website where we have a
large Forum where you can just chat
about comics with us and everyone else
is over there and even super effective
comic book Cass is over there they
aren't right now but I'll force Joel
later
uh Joel's Frozen in the most funniest
face I have ever seen in my
life he's disappeared he's gone and
there cell what the hell we're just
losing people we're losing people it's
droing got to go
guys we'll see you guys next time thank
you for joining us and we'll be here
next Tuesday at 6 PM Eastern yep we'll
catch you guys later peace